[Music]
all right so let's let's pause for a
second and shift sort of to your
politics before we go into some other
stuff because from the critics of yours
they say she's a right-wing maniac and
she's a right hardcore right-wing blah
blah blah now people are saying that
about me too and I find you run do I
bring crazy you yeah and it becomes it
means nothing it just means that you're
not a complete leftist whatever so
there's a or your right-wing whatever we
chatted for just a second before we
started and basically said you're
socially liberal what what what thought
of is right with you is just that you
care about national security is that
pretty much yeah I'm a natural I'm a
9/11 national security conservative you
know the New York Times did interview
with me for my second book title they
must be stopped and you know I mentioned
in it that I voted for Al Gore and a lot
of my friends are like you voted for Al
Gore I said yeah I'm a 9/11 conservative
9/11 make people realize that we are
fighting for the survival of our
civilization we are dealing with people
that want to kill us the national
security issue is an American issue it's
not a Republican issue it's not a
democratic issue it's not a libertarian
issue it's an American issue America has
been attacked under different
administration by radical Islam
regardless of the politics of whoever
was living at the White House
America was attacked the first time
under the Carter Administration in 1979
a Democrat with the hostages in Iran
America was attacked again under Ronald
Reagan administration a Republican in
1983 with the blowing up of the Marines
in Lebanon America was effect under
George Bush senior administration
America was effect under the Clinton
administration the first bombing of the
World Trade Center in 1993 was under
President Clinton a barrel Gregg it was
actually under President Clinton that
the Taliban trained 10,000 al-qaeda
members in Afghanistan now these people
were not being trained for entertainment
they were trying to attack the United
States of America America was attacked
under George Bush jr. administration
every
lookin on 9/11 the only difference
between the attacks of 1993 and 2001 as
the buildings didn't come down and then
people thought if we just elect
President Obama all our sins are going
to be forgiven the whole world is going
to sing Kumbaya yeah obviously that did
not happen so if you do you think that's
his biggest error that when he gave that
Cairo speech and it was sort of the
reset of this whole thing that he sort
of offered an apology for America's
foreign policy and whatever else and
that he bought us no goodwill it didn't
do anything and actually and then you
can argue about the red line in Syria
and a whole bunch of other things that
when were quote-unquote nicer even
though he was at war every day of his
presidency in Afghanistan and drone
strike in Pakistan and all that stuff
but the the niceties just don't fly in
reality no because it's not about nine
cities we are dealing with an enemy bent
on our destruction because of their
ideology and as a matter of fact
President Obama was work he did not
understand the Middle East or was
complicit working with the Muslim
Brotherhood because he thought they
later they are a moderate organization
actually the person that wrote President
Obama's speech which he delivered in
Cairo the first major speech to the
Arabic world was written by the
elevation of the president of isne the
Islamic Society of North America which
is an unindicted co-conspirator in the
largest terrorism trial ever in the
history of the United States in 19 2007
2008 which took place in Dallas Texas
the Holy Land Foundation versus our
government or our government versus the
Holy Land Foundation so this happened
immediately before he came into office
and he started working with the Muslim
Brotherhood he actually forced President
Mubarak who was our ally because we got
the majority of our intelligence out of
Egypt and Jordan other than Israel and
he literally threw Bharat under the bus
and forced Mubarak to accept having the
Muslim Brotherhood leadership in the
first two rows attending his speech in
Cairo yeah to the chagrin of Mubarak
because he wasn't understanding what was
going on and he basically empowered them
to basically become so belligerent
and advance their cause so do you think
Mubarak saw the writing on the wall then
that he was on his way out and what you
think it looked like because it wasn't
Tahrir Square was a couple years later
but at that point Obama basically said
he has to step down then they then they
democratically elected the Muslim
Brotherhood and then it was worse for
year and now they have sort of another
version of Mubarak Obama undermined
Mubarak and Mubarak annuit because
Mubarak knew how close Obama was working
with the Muslim Brotherhood and Mubarak
knew that the Muslim Brotherhood as a
terrorist organization you know they are
classified in Egypt as a terrorist
organization they assemble verified on
Twitter I don't know if you know they've
got the blue check the Muslim
Brotherhood on Twitter their terrorist
organization in Egypt but yeah but not
you know they assassinated President
Sadat to find a peace treaty for Israel
and killed him because he signed the
peace treaty with Israel
that's how Mubarak came to power and
Mubarak had his thumb on them so Obama
thought of Mubarak is a dictator who
gets hit thumb down on these wonderful
people who are just trying you know to
express their opinion America did not
understand the Middle East so Mubarak
knew what was coming and Obama embolden
them yeah okay so let's pause on the
Muslim Brotherhood stuff because you've
given an incredible speech about that
that has about a million views and it's
I would highly recommend it everyone
watch it we'll link to that as well but
the Egypt one is an interesting one to
me because it shows sort of the the
crappy situation we found ourself in
that blue barik even though I can see
you you support him in surveys he
obviously wasn't a great guy was doing a
lot of things again now the press and he
was running he was ruling via the
military but then they got worse it was
worse for the democratically elected
year of the Muslim Brotherhood so what
what then is a sensible solution you
know I mean if the choices are between
military and then a democratically
elected group that's going to be worse
than the military what is a sensible
option for a country like Egypt that is
you know really right let's think of
this thing well the answer lies back 40
years and what happened in the Middle
East in the 60s that's one we said and
70s best one we started seeing the
Muslim Brotherhood strengthen and
remember the Shah of Iran Iran was a
very liberal
fighting Afghanistan was very liberal
societies incredible pictures of women
right back then at universities that
were dressed like well absolutely like
Westerners Egypt was in liberal
societies Syria was a liberal society
now Iraq was a liberal society so when
you look at these so-called what we call
dictators who had their son like the
Shah in Iran having his thumb down on
the how many followers the Shan you that
these are the radical Islamists who want
to establish the Islamic caliphate they
want to resurrect the caliphate
they do not want to have anything to do
with westernization they want to oppress
women they want to put women in shut
doors they weren't meant to grow beard
they were the radical ones so you have
to collect the shah cause or happy that
I said before Bashar now the Sun yes
remember how to selasa the father killed
thirty thousand of them in Hama in Syria
in the 70s thirty thousand Muslim
Brotherhood radical Islamist trying to
rise in Syria so that did the same thing
to them in Egypt the shot tries to do
the same thing to them in Iran so they
were rising all over the Middle East
wanting to establish that elephant
wanted to bring back what we have today
in Iran under Khomeini
or under Isis right now what they're
doing or what Roseville is doing a
Lebanon with the radicalization and we
did not understand what these liberal
leaders we thought of them as dictators
but they had to be what they had to be
and trying to some put their thumb down
on the radicals right it's funny you
described it as liberal but in in that
sense they were liberal maybe not by our
Western standards but I we're not some
movement there and right right but if
you talk to anybody in the Middle East
back then
whether it was Sadat's about signed a
peace treaty with Israel King say find a
peace treaty with Israel
now it takes the Liberal leader to be
able to think I do not want to have
anything to do with that radicalism I
want to reach out and sign a peace
treaty and now look how the
deterioration of the situation whether
in Jordan looking of the last two
percent support yeah that's it how much
of them without getting too far into the
to the Israel part of this because that
because that it could take us another
twenty seven days how much did they just
sort of need the hatred of Israel
so like the two most
stable states in the Middle East are
Jordan and Egypt it's not a coincidence
that they have peace treaties but how
much of these countries just need the
idea of a conflict and then perpetuate
it so for example in Jordan you know
they say there's anywhere from forty to
seventy percent of the Jordanians are
actually Palestinians who don't have
equal rights or in Lebanon are there
something like forty or so jobs that
Palestinians aren't allowed to have and
they have trouble getting citizenship
and all that like they need this
conflict to keep the eye off what their
own governments are doing they don't
need the conflict they can get the jobs
they want they could grow they can
accomplish except I can tell you about
lovin in my own experience
in Lebanon in the refugee camps and the
Palestinian refugee camps when I mean
the Palestinians in refugee camps need
to consult I mean the government's need
it because they have to keep everyone
focused on Israel instead of dealing
with everyone the Middle East they do
not want Israel in the Middle East but
you have to understand the Middle East
is majority Muslim and the Jews are
classified in the Quran as meshes yes
the word meshes in Arabic means self
filth is dogs that's why Muslim say dogs
they think of measures bodily fluid
thesis dislodges the Prophet Mohammed on
his deathbed on his deathbed his last
statement commanding the Muslims to
fight the Jews and kill them and till
the day of judgment death Prophet
Muhammad's last commandment because he
was poisoned by a Jewish woman three
years earlier so in the Muslim mind the
Jews will our eternal enemies they do
not belong in the Middle East because
they are soiling Arab land that's why
they want them out so if you could
withdraw all over all of Israel and
leave only Mutulu just a sliver
the Arabs will not be happy with that
they're going to go after it Mutulu
trying to come every last Jew no that's
the problem
it's not about geography it's about
ideology and that's the problem that
people in the West don't understand okay
so speaking of ideology so now we've
mentioned about Muslim Brotherhood a bit
as I said you gave this incredible
speech about it for people that don't
really understand what it is at all can
you sort of do Muslim Brotherhood 101
and what this ideology that's really
spreading across the world right now is
up to haha
well the Muslim Brotherhood is the
oldest
Islamic terrorist organization in the
world it was founded in 1928 in Egypt by
a group of mullahs and that was and
today the Muslim Brotherhood has 70 of
South Islamic organizations including al
Qaeda Hamas and also Isis you know al
Zawahiri who's now the head of al-qaeda
was imprisoned and exiled from Egypt as
a leader of the Muslim Brotherhood and
but Barry the head of Isis right now was
a member of the Muslim Brotherhood in
our prisons as early as 2011 because he
was a member of the Muslim Brotherhood
so the Muslim Brotherhood its members
are the most highly educated members
there are the lawyers they are as over
here as a surgeon as but very is a PhD
has a PhD in Islamic theology Osama bin
Laden was a businessman engineer
Mohammed are very glitter of the
September 11 attack was an engineer so
the Muslim Brotherhood was founded at
what this was about poverty that's what
people are left alone say it's about
poverty it had the same opportunity it
has nothing to do with poverty it has to
do with ideology this is why you see
people like Osama bin Laden leaving all
their wealth all their Millions I'm
going living in a cave in Afghanistan
this is why you see all Zawahiri a
surgeon living in a hellhole in
Afghanistan this is why you see people
like Mohammad out now or we have Zahra
the second directly the
second-in-command of the 9/11 attack
blow themselves up he was a doctor it
has nothing to do with money
see we in the West think if you have the
swimming pool the Mercedes the nice big
house and the nice zip code why would
you want to kill yourself because we are
judging everything according to Western
values but the Muslim brothers was a
response to the ending of the Caliphate
by Ataturk in 1924 in Turkey when
President at the third give rights to
women to vote give rights to one say in
education gave rights women to choose
whatever they want to do whoever they
want to marry so the Muslim Brotherhood
was launched and when it was launched
people thought that was clubs over its
town will never be resurrected so the
Muslim Brotherhood kept growing and
growing and growing and organizing and
two things happened in the Middle East
that made the Islamists explode
worldwide the discovery of oil in the
Middle East and then Ayatollah Khomeini
coming to power
in 1979 that gave them the money and the
spiritual covering to explode on the
world stage in 1982 the Muslim
Brotherhood wrote a plan and 100 year
plan for radical Islam to infiltrate and
dominate the West and establish an
Islamic government on earth yeah and
this is where your video is about that
I've been mentioned and in that
counterterrorism circles the plan became
known as the project and what makes the
project for unique is it gives tactics
and proposals as to how to use our
open-mindedness against us how to use
our multiculturalism against us they
even talk about certain words that will
make Westerners lay down their guard a
good words like a diversity a tolerance
multiculturalism interfaith does that
sound familiar right now I mean the word
Islamophobia which is a completely
nonsensical idea no one's afraid of the
I of the word you know Islam as an
ideology or afraid of what they had
hereand my right right by the way it's
karma phobia but concocted at the United
Nations by a group of Muslim
organizations saying well we need to
vilify anybody who's going to talk about
Islam or criticize Islam well we in the
West debate I mean people like us who
come from the judeo-christian world the
Bible has come let's reason together
right and Judaism they have people that
go to seminary all they do all day long
is debate that's their job and I think
I'm not being said I don't think that
anything that we're doing here is based
in any sort of biblical anything you're
giving me secular funny story love it
absolutely exactly you know but so the
Muslim Brotherhood started exploding and
they started in this plan talking about
how to get democratically Muslim elected
to the West on all levels of the West
how to get a Muslim interns and
governmental offices so they can have an
inside review as the whole policy is
done on the highest levels they talk
about how to work with like-minded
organizations progressive organizations
that share similar goals this is why
when you see the ACLU working with care
you scratch your head anything to
yourself
how can these two people work together
you've got a radical lefty organization
you know Pro gay for abortion fold
so that you've got the Islamist on the
other hand but the ACLU is being used as
the useful idiots at the hands of people
like care
[Music]